what's going on guys so we just got some
cool news this week about DC's Suicide
Squad the casting a little bit about the
plot but I have a question what the f is
Suicide Squad what's it all about some
of you might be asking the same thing
and we have a cool panel to break it
down with first he writes for DC he
writes the Batwoman comic Wonder Woman
77 and he's also New York Times
bestselling author Mr Mark andreco
welcome back You Hell always good to see
you heck yeah and he is a screen junkie
part of the family he produces movie
fights and uh he's an all-around swell
guy Jason Inman welcome to the show glad
to be here so Suicide Squad uh there
villains who are hired by the government
to go on secret missions what's going on
well they're not actually hired by the
government they're recruited by the
government and in the original comic
done in the 80s by John Ostrander they
were given clasps that had bombs in them
so if they deviated from the mission or
tried to run away they would just kill
them but so that's like the worst
possible house arrest bracelet that you
could possibly exactly exactly the
easiest way I was going to say to
explain if you want to if you're out on
the street and you want to explain the
suicide squad to somebody is just say
it's the Wild Bunch with super villains
forced to go on Black Ops missions what
kind of missions would they go on on the
missions that the superheroes want to
you know Superman and Batman won't kill
so if you know in the comic book they
had them if they wanted to take out a
dictator in a South American
dictatorship they would send them and
and that's what a lot of them were they
was just like oh there's a terrorist
somewhere who runs some weird super
villain organization let's get the
suicide SCH to kill that guy so let's uh
let's break down the casting that's the
big news that came out uh so Jared Leto
is the Joker uh you said the Joker might
be a major plot Point well I don't know
anything for sure but one of the rumors
was and this makes the most sense is
that the suicide squad recruits Harley
Quinn to go after the Joker because it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense for DC
to introduce the Joker in this new
shared universe and have him be kind of
a an anti-hero especially since he's
Batman's number one villain we don't
want to see a friendly Joker go fight
Ben Affleck in two movies and the Joker
has never been a member of The Suicide
Squad in the comics ever Will Smith uh
Deadshot uh so in the in the comics he's
an enemy of Batman he's a hired assassin
he's got one eye he actually started out
as a vigilante in Gotham there's there's
an old story line Batman and Robin went
on vacation and Deadshot put on a suit
and fought crime but he killed criminals
so Batman of course put him in prison
and that got him to The Suicide Squad so
he actually was a hero vigilante he's
really interesting he's really a lot
more tormented and potential
a good guy buried deeply in there so
there's a lot of I can see why Will
Smith would want to play that part I
actually when I heard Will Smith was
going to be cast this movie I figured he
would be playing Colonel Rick flag not
Deadshot because he seems more fitted
for that role and Tom Hardy seems better
for Deadshot than and uh that takes us
to uh Tom Hardy who's playing Rick flag
uh col Rick flag he's basically the the
field commander of the suicide squad and
he was the original he was in the
original Suicide Squad when it was just
in the armed forces division when it was
just civilians and in the man who holds
the leash of the criminals Margot Robbie
is Harley Quinn I think it's perfect she
was so great in The Wolf of Wall Street
and I think she's really got the goods
she's she I think we have a potential
Charlie there and a new one on our hands
wow and this is one of the great Batman
villains that has been deserved to be on
film for a long time we've never seen
Harley Quinn Joker's girlfriend stock
the ultimate Stockholm Syndrome Girl Who
falls in love with the joker it could be
a really it could be the breakout role
of this movie I think it is to be I
think I think she and Jared Leo are
going to be the ones that surprise
everybody because Harley Quinn is also a
hugely popular character I mean the
merchandising money they make on Harley
Quinn at DC is pretty it makes sense
that they're putting her in this movie
ja Courtney as Boomerang you say he
double crosses sometimes tell me a
little all the time he's the least
trustworthy member of the group um he's
just a slimy slimy guy he's just bad
news and he has no superpowers he just
throws boomerangs yeah he's like really
that's it yeah but the boomerangs also
have like razor blades and toxic gas
explode and that sort of thing gotcha so
he's just got a ton of it'll be really
interesting to see how they pulled this
off and make it actually look cool
supermodel Cara delin is enchantress
that that's a really interesting bit of
casting because this movie will come out
I think before Doctor Strange DC is
going to Trump marble by introducing
their magic because the enchantress is
this woman who's possessed by this this
Spirit and the enchantress is just a
killer she has she has multiple
personalities and the enchantress is one
of her other personalities and she makes
Anthony Hopkins look friendly she's just
a psychopath there's completely she's
like the atomic bomb you use her at the
last minute yeah yeah she joins she
joins the squad because the Amanda
Waller and the squad make a promise that
they're like we'll help you get care
take care of this crazy personality but
in fact they want to use it because
she's very powerful and then we talked
about Amanda Waller hasn't been cast yet
who would you like to see play well of
the names I mean there there's there's
so many great African-American actresses
that can play the part there's Octavia
Spencer there's Viola Davis but the most
and there's CCH Pounder who voiced
League cartoon but the most interesting
name in the mix for me is Oprah Winfrey
I think I think you know it would be it
would show it would up her hip Factor
substantially and she's a damn fine
actress what's Amanda Waller's backstory
is she's basically just the ultimate
government agent like she's killed who
she's had to kill to get to the point
where she is and she doesn't take any
crap yeah there's a famous cover from an
issue of the original SE Squad book uh
book with Batman and Amanda Waller and
it's Hirt is going like this and she's
this short kind of rotund black woman in
a skirt and heels she's like she's so
badass she figured out Batman's identity
and used it to threaten him damn she's a
she's a great character how did how did
they all fit together in well they don't
that's why that's what makes the movie
they they don't it's not like you know
super superheroes all tend to have
coffee clutches together but these super
villains they don't hang out and talk
about the heroes they don't go for
schwarma after mission they're all out
they're all out for themselves and
they're all trying to figure out how do
I escape when we're out doing our
missions how do I escape how do I get
rid of this collar or this bomb what do
we think this movie is trying to set up
for the whole um DC slate I think it
just opens up the doors I think it shows
that they're going from Superman
franchises standing alone and Batman
franchises standing alone to really
opening up and catching up to where the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is because
there's also talk that Lex Luthor is
going to be in this there they're in
negotiations with Jesse Eisenberg and
allegedly there's a reference to the
Joker in Batman versus Superman and if
they do the suicide squad's first story
in the story line called Legends The
Suicide Squad went after this villain
called Stone who in the story you found
out was a minion of dark side which
could set up Justice League down the
line that would be super cool so to sum
up here's what we're kind of seeing as
The Suicide Squad movie coming together
Amanda Waller she's on top RI flag just
below are the point person in the
suicide squad and then the members of
The Suicide Squad Boomerang enchantress
Harley Quinn uh Deadshot and potentially
they're going after the joke Joker yeah
we that's been a rumor that's been
bouncing around no one knows if it's
true it makes sense to me should I be
excited about this you should I'm more
excited for this in Justice League there
you have it um are you excited about
this let us know what you think in the
comments below uh the best comment we're
going to send you a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my awesome panel
for coming in and breaking this stuff
down Mark and Draco check out all of the
comics and cool stuff he's a part of
Jason Inman uh check him out on movie
fights he won the last movie fight which
pisses me off off um I want to thank you
for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up
on Twitter
byebye so you just want the same plot of
the first movie but with a packed theme
park and that's different enough for you
yeah cuz that first one was one of the
best movies of all time uh see I don't
know agree with that I think you need
to L world was